bonjour narry la feuille ce bonjour
bienvenue dans la partie ravi de vous
accueillir
et où vous allez au vous voulez ou
quelques marches faites attention et
puis vous pouvez observer et comme je
sais que vous êtes plutôt
attentive aux questions d'architecturé
de déco esteyrie alalala snoop il aime
moins que j'adore moi je n'ai en noir
elle est belle aussi en verte bon très
bien orange n'ont donc celui là aussi si
elle est super bon voilà je vous laisse
observer parce que effectivement je sais
que vous avez un goût prononcé pour les
chantiers là quand vous observez comme
ça à première vue on regarde quoi on
garde tout faux
alors attendez achoui parce qu'il faut
que ouais en fait j'ai une obsession mon
talent quand j'arrive dans un endroit
c'est vrai que je le leur dessine dans
ma tête mais c'est un problème
psychologique un jeu mais là c'est un
peu tôt foot passion trible à chaque
fois que vous arrivez jeu même chez des
amis tout ça surtout chez des amis et
surtout si c'est la première fois je
j'abats des cloisons mentalement je sais
vraiment c'est un toc ah oui et du coup
vous avez un grand garage à la maison
avec une sorte d'atelier pour pouvoir
poursuivre votre espèce de la leur mon
père il avait sauvé sa chez moi quand
j'étais petit mais moi maintenant non je
suivais jadis je faisais beaucoup de
travail manuel et jeu j'en fait plus
malheureusement
génial ça c'est ça c'est merveilleux
beaters sam pellegrino je suis pas sûr
que c'est comme la poutargue il ya des
choses qui sont vraiment culturel
la poutargue je crois que pour aimer il
faut être juif aux sardes et le bitter
san pellegrino je pense qu'il faut être
italien est comme moi je suis tout ça et
oui voilà alors expliqué quand même
peut-être tous les spectateurs se
connaissent pas cet apéritif d'abord
c'est sans alcool pas toujours non mais
moi je le vois avec de la vodka bah
voilà
bastien c1 comme on dit un os un
apéritif un soda est souvent le cas
ouais faut aimer l'amertume
moi je me bats beaucoup dans ma vie pour
ne pas être amer mais j'aime les choses
amères au bout pour que vous vous battez
comme ça pourrais je trouve que c'est
une des pires choses l'amertume je pense
que ça fait beaucoup souffrir ceux qui
la ressentent et
et pour l'entourage c'est atroce c'est
la pire chose et puis je me demande si
on est amer c'est qu'on doit être un peu
malhonnête parce que il ya quand même
tout un faisceau de choses dont on est
plus ou moins plus ou moins responsable
dans la vie ou qu'on peut modifier en
tout cas ce qui nous arrive n'est pas
obligé de produire de l'amertume donc ça
aussi vous passer ça au crible en fait
vous repérez ça et vous essayez plutôt
de non je parle plutôt de moi je sais
pas je dise pas plus sévère avec moi
même et plus douce et tendre avec les
autres à votre santé marina pour merci m
évidemment en confiance on est on est
ravi de vous recevoir j'adore ça alors
il ya un autre truc et nous devons tous
italienne pour ceux qui vont en italie
ce le kinect mais qui note que c'est un
coca italien et c'est bien meilleur que
le coca parce que c'est plus amer voilà
j'adore ça ça c'est vraiment laid ça
c'est ça c'est l'enfance ase alors
effectivement il ya plusieurs origines 1
il ya l'italie la france un grand père
reçu une grand mère juive égyptienne du
côté maternel une grand mère allemande
et un grand père italien du côté
paternel ça fait une sacrée mixité une
sacrée richesse aussi c'est un peu
foutraque parfois
oui bah oui oui je pense que je pense
que c'est pas rien en fait même si moi
j'ai grandi là où je suis né en gros je
pense que c'est pas rien d'être issu
d'une famille qui vient de l'immigration
même si prague complètement honnête
c'est que des immigrés mais c'est quand
même globalement une immigration
bourgeoise donc évidemment plus
confortable que les autres mais je pense
que l'exil c'est un vrai c'est un vrai
sujet je pense qu'être élevé par des
exilés des gens qui ont dû s'intégrer
faire l'effort d'une langue qui était
une culture pour en adopter une autre
trouver ou pas une place et puis
évidemment notre succès immigration il
ya quand même ma grand mère juive qui
est arrivé en france
je crois en
1908 dit se soucier truc là donc
improbable la seconde guerre mondiale
parce qu'il parlait donc ces gens qui se
sont cachés bah oui donc forcément qui
on voit fort jeu je n'ai aucun doute que
sa marque des générations une sage
enfonce une porte ouverte france marina
entre parisienne à mettre 60 de deux
enfants actrice